one of the most prolific touchdown
makers and wide receivers that this game
has ever seen he's Antonio Brown of the
Pittsburgh Steelers hello Antonia do you
remember the first conversation we had
postgame on NFL Network remember that
conversation yeah that was a while back
I think you torched the Cleveland Browns
right and then you stopped by and it was
me you and Earth
that's right DeLand was there yeah I
remember that brother what was that
moment like for you I mean you that was
your be gonna have your coming-out
parties back in that day man I was such
a surreal moment you know second year
you know I have an opportunity to
finally started to get an itch and get
in on the offense and play with being
and be able to be in some of the
packages and work in my game and I'm
having an explosive game I remember that
night you know and coming up there with
the cars after the game and that was a
great moment brother so much was is
being has been made about Tom Brady
six-round status and how he wears that
on as a chip on his shoulder what about
you well I'm not Tom Brady status you
know I got a long way to go to get there
but you know I'm being grateful man I've
been grateful I'm just truly
tremendously great food play really
great organization with some great
teammates great quarterback on some
great situation you know experiences
something says you know what and I'm
just decided you know hungry young
player is carving his way making Mitch
my Tom Smith and I want in you to just
grow in it now be my best self and here
we are another year to get reacquainted
without goes and and do some things we
love to do in uh hope they win the
championship no that's very very humble
of you but we're showing a stat on the
screen right here we're over a four-year
span over the last four years you've had
41 more catches than Jerry Rice had from
93 to 96
tonio I mean they talked about for years
fans you've been on fire yeah I mean I'm
grateful man honor to play with Ben you
know having that chemistry with a
quarterback man is uh something that's
uh amazing you know fun to be a part of
some especially now it makes the game so
much fun you know when you have that
kind of charisma with your quarterback
and that kind of charisma with any
football club you know makes it really
fun and exciting do you really think Ben
was thinking of retiring this past
offseason uh yeah I think so man you
know he's done everything from a general
perspective you know he to Championships
you know top ten in passing passing
yards in the NFL you know so when you
when you not been and you're looking at
looking at it from outside looking in
you got to think okay what's the
motivation you know I know he just had a
kid he got three beautiful kids I know
how important it is for him to spend
time with his family he's a real family
man you just sit back and think we just
lost the biggest game of all year you
know the championship game and you know
blood father left a bad taste in his
mouth and had him you know I didn't
start an offseason on the wrong foot you
know family time we just lost the
biggest game of his career and now I
just trying to take the thoughts and my
mind and being him and try to fathom
what he was experiencing or what he was
thinking but uh I'm just glad he renewed
his commitment and been on top of his on
top of his game and it's been fun to
have him have him there man I couldn't
fathom being without him what challenges
does a levy on Bell face being out as he
did for as he was for training camp
showing up on September 1st and you got
a game coming up Sunday in Cleveland
Antonio well no unique individual and
physical condition and procedures
anything he's a highly professional and
I know he's gonna do everything to get
his body into shape and get his - shape
we decided to see him work man we
expecting some great things from him we
can't say what he can't do and what he
won't do we gotta be in the regards of
living in the moment of what he's
willing to do and I know he's willing to
do whatever it take for us to win and 30
or 40 carries whatever the case may have
you to get the situation or the game
done
he's gonna be one and go alright so
let's talk Super Bowl here Antonio let's
talk about the big game here because
everyone's there's a lot of folks think
the Patriots are making it and the
Raiders if they didn't lose Derek Carr
last year now he's back that they can
make it what about the Steelers focus on
getting better each week you know in our
best sales and each week we just focus
on that week you know we'll get to that
later way down in the Rye but uh we're
just thinking the focus right now on the
Cleveland Browns we got a tough opponent
we going in today house to the dog pound
you know we gotta be ready to go well
you gotta Hayden now you got Hayden on
your side Antonio how about that we got
a lot of em oh you know we're just gonna
put it out there in a light of fire and
make it be explosive and hope they win
some game so Mike Tomlin has not given
you the green light to talk smack about
the Browns and make a boastful
prediction for the Super Bowl he hasn't
done that hey Tony yeah I would hope
that Tommen's giving you the green light
to be boastful no nah man I think most
boasting is never good man being anxious
is never good you know I don't try to
tell myself all the things that's going
on that I've been able to do obviously
I'm aware of them and I acknowledge them
but I'm not setting myself up with it
every day because you know the Steelers
don't need me no one need me and you got
to keep that attitude in life you know
not only playing football of you're
working out at 9:00 to 5:00 you know no
one needs you you know no matter what
you do it's all about what you're doing
right now you know the past have no
relevance and in it you know you can
feel good about what you did a long time
ago but it all started what you willing
to do and what you're gonna do right now
you know people don't remember what you
did yesterday
you know they can't know you to be
productive and do something today so I
kind of shape my mentality around that
attitude and regards I'm not thinking of
what I already done and you know the
things that you said I got four years
more yards of Jerry Rice you know and
obviously those things made me feel like
I'm doing that me feel great it like I'm
doing something well but those things
not at the forefront um
and me thinking that I'm just some type
of you know I mean you got to play it
down in your mind and just focusing
really focus on getting better and
working in regards to yourself and then
now you know women is all about what's
important now you know what's important
now is I'm preparing for a big game
against Cleveland Browns and then I'm
getting myself prepared weekend a week
out to do my job the best of my ability
you know the past don't matter nothing I
have done behind me you have matter it
only matter what I do right now in this
moment a couple more minutes left with
Antonio Brown is your courtesy of Sunday
Ticket which has been on DirecTV
exclusively for the last 20 years
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
the relaxed celebration rules Antonio
you ready you got something planned what
do you got for me man we got the Soul
Train line we got the casino around the
crap table okay no we got the fall
asleep in the end zone okay we got
destiny to activation dance after you
just made the kill the videogame
celebration mmm I mean there's so many
options managed there's so many ways to
celebrate you just got to celebrate the
right way okay all the way no I mean and
you know you can't jump on that goalpost
right you know that yeah I can't I can't
cut a rug I can't jump on the goalpost I
can't shake what my mama gave me I just
gotta say the rules by Howard Howard
holiday Mendes on you can't shake what
your mama gave you is essentially I
don't know if that's been in the rule
book but that's a good way to put it
though that's a good way that's a good
way to point that out if you could pay
last one for you before we talk to
Sunday Ticket if you could remove
yourself from it you could pay
hard-earned antonio brown dollars to
watch one wide receiver play football in
the NFL who would that be
NFL receiver play outside of yourself
outside of myself
mmm-hmm I probably go see the kid in New
York Odell Beckham man one of my close
friends he's always excited you know
he's gonna give you that celebration and
endzone you know he's gonna give you
that explosive the game-changing play
he's gonna get
you had a nice one-hand catch you know I
didn't gonna give you a lot of things
that could make you exciting while you
watch and he's really entertaining so I
gotta go with the Blanc the blonde
light-skinned kid with the huge fingers
out there in New York with him like you
did with Brandon Marshall last year do
you got anything like that him no we
don't do those type of things like
betting each other out the most we just
hold each other's a high standard being
a being great examples making those
explosive plays willing out into the
playoffs and you know trying to meet
each other in the Super Bowl that's how
it goes every year within each other it
to do something that's never been done
for the culture for the history of the
NFL of what are you growing up you know
inspire others through something I've
never been done and meet each other in a
Super Bowl I know you're you're you're
getting ready for another big season and
I've just still has been on NFL Sunday
Ticket right you're part of the campaign
to let everybody know to to go out and
make sure that they can watch the other
games wherever they live no matter where
they are Sunday Ticket commercial I'm
taking part in the NFL Sunday Ticket
commercial with DIRECTV and I felt
Sunday Ticket you know it's the only
place you can see every game out of
market game the red zone and fantasy
zone the way you could check on your
players highlights their production you
know the NFL Sunday Ticket Doctor TV
DirecTV column slash NFL and I'm just
grateful to be you know the partner with
these guys for over 20 years DirecTV has
been my exclusive home to the NFL Sunday
Ticket you know I watch all the games
there you know it's honor being a part
of them yep DirecTV comm / NFL - check
it all out an Antonio last question for
you this may sound odd but we were
talking with the wrestler Chris Jericho
before about Cologne
what cologne do you wear Antonio do you
wear cologne Tom for guys type of spray
okay
now hide the tone for now do you do you
missed it in the air and walk into the
mist or do you apply the Tom Ford
directly to Antonio Brown
yeah I just hit my collar by the neck
you know I usually hit my wrist because
I usually hit my hand and then rub it on
my hands and I just wiped me down now
next level though do you do it on
Sundays for games do you wear the
Colonna on Sunday Sunday is always
important to feel fresh I want to D be
when you come over and see me he be like
damn this guy smells great you know
thinking refreshments when you see me
tricks of the trade tricks of the trade
and I got Cologne Enzo yeah it's Cologne
endzone there's it that's that's another
one am i spray myself yeah can you do
that can you if you score week one do a
cologne and I don't mean to mess with
the plan but if you do a cologne endzone
dance you'll it'll be a shout-out to the
rich eyes and show listeners and viewers
it's not to put that in there maybe I
spray olive oil on my hair didn't I
reach it to my side pans and then get a
little Cologne spray for the rich
ottenschot that's it Antonio Brown I'm
looking forward to seeing you in the end
zone and for that dance YouTube that's
antonia braun at a DAT for the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that download our app please
just if it's a memory thing just delete
other apps you don't need those apps
this app the rich eyes and show up you
need that